[Music]
hello everyone my name is george
i'm a data scientist at the financial
times based in london
and today i'm going to walk you through
our current pipeline that we developed
using our studio connect
and then try and compare
that pipeline with the previous one we
had and see
what we have changed and how we have
improved
so we're going to start with a brief
introduction to the financial times and
the team
and we're going to then move on to
describing what data science means for
the financial times
and what types of problems we're trying
to solve
and then we're going to have an overview
of
our new pipeline and the previous
pipeline all of the technologies
involved
and a point-to-point comparison between
the two
finally we're going to go through our
agile
practices and see how connect and
our new pipeline have helped so the
financial times
as you might know is a newspaper it was
first published in
1888 in london where we are still based
so the main offices are in london the
financial times is operating on a
subscription model
which means any of our users needs to
have an active subscription
either a company or an individual
so in terms of data we have all of the
subscription data both for individuals
and companies which is really nice
if you want to aggregate things or track
events and users over time
we have behavior and demographic data as
you would expect
and we track events both from our
site and our app so all of that data
allows us to
do a lot of analysis and develop
different data science models that we
then provide to different teams within
the company
so we have many different stakeholders
from across the business
so moving on to the team currently there
are six of us uh
back in 2017 uh there were just two of
us
so we have managed to tripling size over
the past
two and a half years and we are now
planning to
double again over the next couple of
months so the team is
adam cloudy grey solid simon and me
it's really interesting how a weird
white background we all have though we
all have one thing in common
which is none of us is a software
developer
and as you will see in the decisions and
technology we're using
this has driven some of the decisions on
what tools we use and how we use them
and
what the processes within the team are
so data science in the ft if we wanted
to summarize that
into three into just a few points we
would end up with
three points so the first one is that
we're trying to create models that
allow users to become more engaged with
the product we offer either
the onset products or the app and we
we usually try to do that by adding more
personalization to the user journey so
either by promoting specific types of
content
or different products that the user
might have not
interacted with in the past a
second point is that we try to always
optimize
and make all of all of the different
parts of our acquisition funnel to be
better
so we get better at acquiring new
subscriptions
and maintaining those subscriptions
and finally we develop a set of
different metrics
to make sure that the health of the
business is
looks good so from things like rfe which
is our key engagement metric
which is based on recency frequency and
volume of
reader activity to ltv which is
our lifetime value calculation
that we use across our user base
so on top of those three goals we have
developed a few
different models as you would expect so
things like
nest next best action and topic
recommendations
so we try to identify products or things
that the user hasn't done
on site or on the app recently and we
try to
send them a reminder or just a promotion
for that particular
product and also in terms of
recommendations we provide content
personalized content and personalized
topics for users to
interact with we
make predictions for our for the volume
of new subscriptions
based on past business performance
we have attribution modeling where we
try to identify marketing campaigns
that are real drivers of acquisitions
and growth for the business
and then use that knowledge to
make better better decisions for where
to spend our marketing budget
we segment users uh in many various
different levels and then we use that
those segments
for analysis or for data science model
models finally we have
a set of models around identifying
potential leads for b2b contracts
so if we identify a user that is a
decision maker or someone that
is coming from a specific company that
we know
used to have a contract with us or maybe
has one and we want to grow that
we can then ask them to move on to a b2b
account so into our sprint cycle
we as i said in the beginning we use
agile principles to some extent so we
split our time into week sprints
we have our planning and prioritization
meetings a few months before
the actual start of the sprint where we
define requirements and
objectives and dependencies with other
teams or specific data points
we involve all of the relevant
stakeholders in that discussion to make
sure that we are doing things that are
relevant for the business then we have a
kickoff meeting just before we start
working on the sprint where we
have a more detailed discussion on
exactly how we're going to do
all of the objectives and how we're
going to go about
fulfilling all of the requirements we
create cards for our dashboard
and then make sure that all of the
existing dependencies have been met
then we hold daily standups where we
again
meet will with all all of the relevant
stakeholders
we saw results from early
analysis we have done we ask for
feedback we make sure that we are going
in the right direction
and then in the end of the sprint we
have a retro where we take note of
things that went well
things that didn't go as well and next
steps for future iterations on the same
project
so now let's actually go and see what
the
current and the old pipelines look like
so back in 2017
we decided we wanted to create our own
custom pipeline
so we found a tool or a framework called
luigi
which is written in python and it's a
really nice tool if you want to create a
custom pipeline
uh for any language really
so before that we used to have a big
dependency with our data platform stream
so anything we published would go
through their platform so we want to
move away from that
that's why we decided to go with luigi
so at that time
the pipeline was hosted on aws and
amazon services so
all of the data was in redshift and we
would have to
create a separate sql script for any
query
we were running against thread shift
we would then have to create docker
containers where we would have all of
the r scripts
and so would load the data from red
shift do any data wrangling load the
model
execute the model within the docker
container and then
send the data back to redshift and
buckets
in s3 and on top of that we would have
jenkins
to make sure that we schedule the jobs
to run whenever we need we needed them
to
and i think i forgot to mention so luigi
is written in python
and the way that luigi works is you need
to provide the dependencies and the
order in which the steps
need to run and we do that by
providing a python script so as you can
see there are a few different
technologies
we used to write sql r and python so it
was hard to extend
hard to maintain and really hard for new
joiners to get up to speed with but
it was really successful until we
started to grow as a team
so then we found out about our studio
connect which is now at the core of our
pipeline
we also now moved all of our
infrastructure into
google which was not a decision of the
data science team it was a decision from
the data platform stream
but again it proved to be successful and
we're quite happy with that as well
so now the data comes from bigquery and
then we go straight into our studio
connect where
we run any r script our script we load
any model execute the model
and then store the outputs in bigquery
and buckets in gcs
so as you can see here all of the code
required is just
in r so we can have interactions with
bigquery or the buckets
with using the relevant packages in r
so it's really nice to maintain really
easy for someone that knows
how to code in order to get up to speed
with and
we're quite happy with it until up to
now
so if we want to compare the two
pipelines
and so we said that now we only have r
whereas in the past we had three
different
languages so that's definitely a benefit
we removed a lot of the complexity
involved which was
not really necessary as it seems
we can now publish and schedule things
in just a few
minutes whereas in the past it would
take around a day
and if you were a new joiner maybe a
week
we can make the most out of shiny
dashboards and shiny apps and just
deploy anything we want
uh really easy uh
and also there is great integration to
our team's capabilities as i said we're
not software developers so
maintaining a pipeline that involves
docker and luigi
and interacting with aws was much much
harder than what we have now
and as you will see also in the end
the current pipeline fits greatly with
all of the agile processes we have
so now we can briefly go through what
setting up our studio connect
involves so as i said we are using
google but it would be more or less the
same process if you are using amazon or
any other
cloud provider so for us
it was just a matter of going to the
console create a new instance
which can be a very small linux server
in the beginning and then you can
directly ssh onto the server install of
all of the basic requirements like a
version of r
a version of java and r studio connect
itself
you can also create a server-wide data
store if you want to
allow for data to be loaded between
different jobs or
different different runs of the same job
and finally you just need to configure
packets and bigquery
create the relevant credentials and then
use those inside their studio connect
and that's it so in in the beginning it
might have taken us
a couple of days to get everything
configured
and create the proper documentation if
we were to replicate the server now
it would probably take just a couple of
hours
so finally moving back to our
sprint cycle and how our studio connect
and the new pipeline have
made us better working in an agile
setting so creating markdown reports
and providing results from any early
analysis we do is really easy now we can
move between
research and development to deployment
whenever we need to
we can deploy multiple versions of the
same model
again that's really really easy and on
top of that we can create
dashboards or alerts to make sure that
all of the models that we have
look fine and there is no performance
drop or
any failure in the scheduled runs
so then as an overview uh we
went quickly through those so we saw how
our studio connect is now part of our
pipeline and how it has improved
the way we do data science we briefly
described how
we configured and set up
our new pipeline using google
infrastructure
and we saw how
the deploying and scheduling markdowns
and dashboards have
made us better in working in an agile
setting
and finally how this also allows us to
make sure that stakeholders are engaged
and we
can welcome feedback throughout the
sprint cycle
so that was it that was it for me
just a reminder we're also hiring as i
said we're trying to double in size
i'm not sure how relevant this is
because most positions are going to be
in london but
feel free to follow the link and contact
either the team or me directly
thank you very much
so we have a a couple questions that
came through the first one is
um what parts of the pipeline are not
replaced with our studio connect
are not replaced by our studio connect
uh all of the our logic and the
interactions
uh with the database or the buckets
or how we execute models so it's yeah
the things that were replaced that might
be easier to answer
so we replaced jenkins and the
monitoring
and the dashboarding with all of the
capabilities of us to do connect
another question from glenn uh how do
you handle shiny dashboards that require
querying large amounts of data
that take considerable time
uh so we do use uh we do cast
the data so if there has been a more
recent run within the same day or within
the same
whatever period we want to update the
dashboard in
uh it's faster if it's not the first
time because we use the cast data
if it's the first one and the query time
is
quite long then the dashboard will take
quite a long tool
to load and uh one last question so is
there something intrinsic
to use rcd connect that motivated the
switch from s3
to the google cloud well gcs
no so so the move between amazon and
google was completely
coming from our data platforms team
because i think there are packages to
interact
both with aws or gc gcs so it's like
it's the same
we should have time for one one last one
so what type of challenges have you had
with scheduling jobs in connect
uh i don't think we had any issues with
scheduling
on a like time schedule we
one thing we would really really like to
have
is to have tricky trigger based
like runs of models so if we could have
some rules
under which the model would run instead
of just specifying that
the job needs to run every hour every
day to
have maybe another job to go in bigquery
check a field if the field had changed
then
run the model doesn't make sense thank
you
thank you